what is going on there reject nation we
are going to watch today from our friend
paul over at heavy spoilers stranger
things season four ending theories the
hidden twist explained in season five
predictions talked extensively with paul
about this show so i'm excited to see
what his video entails proud of the man
he's been killing it lately if you guys
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated if you have not seen our
stranger things season 4 volume 2
reactions you can go check them out
they're here on the channel right now
let's get into action
[Music]
so stranger things 4 volume 2 takes
things to the max with a big ending that
sees several characters dying
includes dr brenner eddie and max who
dies during the battle with beckner max
though she's brought back max is left a
little worse for wear and come the
conclusion she's in an unresponsive coma
it's a big ending and the finale sees
max using herself as bait in order to
draw beckner out so that steve nancy and
robin can go to his body and burn him
whilst he's distracted this works really
well with them getting the drop on him
whilst he's fighting 11 and max is is
henry like impervious to fire it wasn't
exactly like a burning when when 11 sent
him into the upside down but it was like
a burning i mean look at him
and now he's just still still roaming no
yeah he's just so much scar tissue now
that in order to actually burn him alive
you have to throw him in like a real
volcano or something ooh mustafar
unfortunately though he gets most of the
way through his ritualistic murder and
he not only blinds max but he also
breaks several of her bones killing her
in the process eleven reaches out to her
mind and she manages to revive her but
it is possible that she should have let
her city sink into the
void
using naked memories she pulls her back
from the brink but she may be harboring
something much worse in vechna now
throughout this video we're going to be
going through our theories on what's
going on with her how wekner may be
alive and who his next victim is
max
theory time
i gotta get a theory time
now the final 15 minutes of volume 2 has
11 not only visiting max in hospital but
she also attempts to reach out to her
through the void we find max in an
unresponsive coma and nurselle tries to
get through to her on the psychic plane
to see if she can pull her back that way
however her mind is completely devoid of
any life or signs that max is there and
this could be because she's technically
brain dead this is also reflected in
what lucas says too do they know when
she awake
no
[Music]
they say she might not
her heart stopped
for over a minute
she died
i mean clinically then she came back
doctors don't know how
they say it's a miracle
now clinically she died and came back
but her consciousness didn't because of
this she's now an empty vessel and it is
possible that vecna also now exists in
her mind using her as a way to continue
living in the season finale
of
when steve and the gang went to check to
see if his body was there he'd got out
of it like nancy did her relationship
when sexy steve smiled at her
although he was destroyed in this
physical sense will confirms that he's
still out there and we see this
reflected in the environment not only is
the doorway to hell starting to bleed
the upside down into hawkins but there
also exists a black cloud off in the
distance that slightly resembles the
mind player okay so wait a minute so
this theory that paul is presenting
right here is that vecna lives within
max's mind now somehow or or at the very
least this could open a portal for him
to do as such yeah i've heard uh another
theory going around i think someone
commented on our temperature there's a
comment about it reflecting on paul's
channel too fekna says he absorbs people
that he may have absorbed max max's
consciousness was absorbed by vechna so
it actually resides with vechna now
versus the opposite like it's kind of an
inverse of what i think paul's actually
suggesting i feel like that would be
more likely given everything that
happened it would make more sense that
he would absorb her essence or her
spirit somehow yeah that was like yeah
her body is definitely brain dead
however her consciousness is actually
still with vecna maybe somehow in season
five you know like when countering vecna
through mind [ __ ]
somehow max will come in and help save
the day maybe not actually come back to
her body and get to live but still get
to be a hero in her own right maybe it
will be like a freddy krueger thing
where it's like spirits trapped within
than rebel or something like that as a
child young creel used to be fascinated
with spiders and he drew the shape that
would go on to terrorize hawkins this
was clearly how he viewed himself as
being and upon going to the upside down
he said the following i saw a means to
realize my potential
to transcend my human form
to become
the predator i was always
born it makes sense that if his physical
body was to be destroyed that he'd then
take on something that looked more like
the mind flayer for his final form
however i don't think that he's this
cloud per se it's more there just as a
warning of what's to come now i believe
that vaccinate is licking his wounds and
he's hiding out of max recovering along
with her the seriousness is so creepy
how this is possible at several points
obviously there is of course will their
character
was infected with shadow particles and
this created a symbiosis between him and
vechna that he still feels to this day
he didn't fully take over the character
but he was very much a parasite within
him similar to what i believe he's doing
with max there's also the fact that
max's mind was used as a battleground
between him and eleven it's a bit
confusing as to how it all plays out but
basically max goes to the creel house
and then she draws out wekner who from
his hiding place then psychically enters
her mind using a little nina and the
boys 11 is then able to project herself
out there so that the pair can battle it
out in max's brain what i'm really
hoping for and i'm sure a lot of you
guys are hoping for too that somehow
with the fact that will has maintained
being connected to the upside down or or
vector perhaps in the season five finale
somehow will is able to use this torture
this trauma that he has just been living
with morning noon and night and be able
to become a hero in some way you know i
saw this like interesting tick tock
going around that was showing that how
vecna might actually still have might
have really truly been planted since
season one the first time will was taken
it was taken the first time will was
taken the bell chime did go off that
resembles vector that could have been
the duffer brothers just being like hey
this bill trump let's kind of use it to
our advantage or it could have been
intentional since the very first season
hey maybe by season five will will have
awakened you know extra kinetic powers
or something like that maybe all this
exposure to the upside down will somehow
bring him closer to 11 inability that
would be amazing now having access to
this due to being one of his victims
means that wekner can technically come
and go as he pleases throughout the
first volume he watched as those he
stalked ended up seeing vivid visions of
him before he eventually launched his
final attack during the time between
this he'd retreat back to his body but
if he no longer had this to go back to
he'd likely have to hide out in max i
believe that he's actually somewhat
feeding off eleven though she might be
completely unaware of it in the final
few scenes we see eleven spinning a
coca-cola bottle and in between it we
get flashes of her time at max's bedside
when she reached into her mind coca-cola
has been something that's popped up
throughout the series and at several
points this infamous string has been
used to show 11's abilities i think the
way that this editor is carried out and
the order of the scenes could hint
towards what's going on and why beckner
is using her for example we get the
coca-cola scene a quick cut to 11
reaching out to max hopper's return and
then the dark cloud coming in the way
the sequence is set up makes it seem
like it's all connected
now
an abusing 11 is a way to power himself
up due to their ties for example love is
something that definitely empowers 11
and having hopper and joyce's return
could have added the slight boost that
wekner needed to then push the upside
down out the chill that will gets on the
back of his neck comes immediately after
this and though i might be reaching i
might it does seem like these moments
are played out like this for a specific
reason all of it's very specific as
we've come to learn i do love the idea
that because this whole thing with vecna
becoming more powerful as this
absorption machine i do believe that in
some way he does need 11 to be at like
maximum power so that way he can use her
abilities like he might not be strong
enough individually but if he can take
the powers of 11 then he'd be
unstoppable and that'd be kind of like a
crazier like reveal upon reveal this
whole time he that's why he's never just
gone out and just killed 11 directly but
has been trying to take her oh so he can
like complete himself and like ascend to
some kind of other world it'll be like
superman and lois
merge with your bizarro self eleven in
the upside down world now max being lost
in the void could also come back around
and potentially she may be the key to
stopping wekner as well bringing her
back from the brink and having the pair
fight it out in her mind for who gets
control over her body would be a big
battle and something that could end up
being the way that the series progresses
i can actually see eleven possibly
venturing back into max's mind and
she'll start to explore the darkness
within it until she comes across wekner
who will have max's hostage but it's my
mind
not his right
so i should be able to control where i
am
i just need to
push him away
the pair might potentially fight it out
there and 11 could end up winning which
would free max and allow her to come
back this might then lead wagner into
going off into another one of his
potential puppets aka will will early on
oh my god
massive ties to the upside down and
though max took a lot of focus in the
fourth season when we're talking human
characters that beckner has his sights
on he'd definitely be higher up than her
because he can still feel beckner i
think that he'd be another possible
vessel that he could end up playing into
this is also hindered if we look at the
origins of the name wagner which we of
course know comes from dungeons and
dragons this powerful wizard has several
abilities that also include possession
explaining how he could potentially take
over the future characters i don't know
there's something about me that morbidly
likes the idea of will suffering more
just bringing it back
to him just under this control i don't
know why it just sounds amusing to me
after all this time it's just like god
damn this show just loves to beat this
kid up so much i think it would make it
feel like there is a design to will's
overall suffering because after a while
it does start to feel like ah what do we
do with will i don't know let's just
make him suffer in silence so like to
have him then be imbued with vecna and
have to go up against eleven would be
heart crunching yeah i'd be the worst
there's also the fact that we know
shadow particles exist out in russia and
he may end up attempting to get access
to them though murray bust out the
flamethrower to take out some demagogue
or gas i don't believe that the shadow
particles themselves were destroyed and
we lingered on them long enough for me
to believe that they'll be brought back
in some form or another now it's a long
trip for them to fly to hawkins so this
might have just been used as a way to
explain the shadow particles before we
learned that wekner manipulated them in
order to attack hawkins so this could
have just been a way to hint to the
final reveal before we got it but let me
know below exactly what you think now i
think that the other members
are becoming vectors victims and that
once he's back to full power he'll find
a way to hunt the heroes of hawkins once
more who he's after is anyone's guess
but dustin does fit the profile of one
of the people he'd target through max we
discover that those he goes after tend
to have faced some form of trauma and
they harbor feelings of guilt that make
them easy to manipulate this could be
seen in destin who could end up oh my
god no over the fact that eddie died to
save him this was of course also
murdered in max who felt like she was
personally responsible for billy's
passing dustin could share this too as
that he was getting away but he turned
around to face the bats out of hell
which left him gone when the morning
come you know what i honestly would
prefer if he's gonna choose a victim i
prefer it to be joyce i think joyce is
the one who's had
so much guilt to deal with and her
character has not been feeling like the
most essential i don't wanna say she's
non-essential it's just you know she she
was like the star of the first season
and now she's just kind of like this
amusing supporting character who's just
kind of funny once in a while but really
he's not giving that much weight anymore
and i think to do from your season one
to season five to really bring it full
circle imagine her dealing with the
amount of guilt and loss that she's had
to deal with over the course these last
four seasons and how much that weight
would uh take a toll on her especially
now that she's back in hawkins herself
well that would get a nice sort of
change up in the in just the motifs too
because i feel like so much of the kid's
stuff sort of kept with the kids and
isolated so then to have that boundary
crossed of like oh crap we're facing
yeah you know in this in this perverse
form one of our most beloved and close
familial characters i think would be a
nice twist on things and it would
actually give hopper an opportunity it
would make that season five personal for
hopper now too especially if it's
joyce's life that's the one being
endangered or threatened by vechna a
opportunity it really makes me wonder if
they'll actually kill some of the core
cast members next season as currently
seems like they're playing it slightly
safe when it comes to those they murder
sure eddie was a big death but he and
jason feel like they were created just
for the season so that they could be
killed off now that brenner is dead i
also hope that dr owens comes back as
well to someone
and take care to the next level the next
the 12.
you suck
now he's also a character that we don't
really know what happened to and it's
unlikely that the military will still
trust him he did however plead with the
army to bring ellen alive and perhaps
after seeing the chopper downed they'll
realize that trying to assassinate her
isn't the best way to go about it not
really connected to the original theory
on this video but i thought i'd just
throw it in there so you get a bit of
extra bang for your buck on the video
and you bloody did didn't you yeah i'm
too bloody good to you but what i'd love
to hear are your thoughts on what's
going on i do think that if the 11 died
some type of ultimate sacrifice it would
also bring it full circle i remember the
duffer brothers saying that they did
intention originally intend to kill off
11 uh but you know
she's too
too much of a commodity executive
producers came in and said hey hey hold
on a second this is way too popular of a
character yeah she's great but i think
especially if you're gonna put a final
stamp like we are declaring this is the
final season for sure i think killing
off 11 would be heartbreaking and
devastating but it kind of seems like
it's destined for that path too it could
be very very meaningful i know there's
probably a lot of different ways that
the series could go so make sure you
comment below and let me know for this
one big time
anytime all right well thanks for that
video paul that was really well done
just certainly sparked the mind now we
just gotta wait like four more years for
season five to come out and we're gonna
be rock and roll and from here on out
but guys what do you think about these
did what are your craziest theories for
stranger things five or the ending of
stranger things four leave them down
below you can subscribe to the heavy
spoilers channel please do so help get
this gato a million he deserves it also
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell last but not least
let's do a
brian perry got a message from you
saying that you were pledged for this
tier for may and june and that you
didn't get a shout out i'm sorry about
that i mean we have like a list here of
everyone that's pledged on patreon
automatically does it your name wasn't
there i blame john plain and simple my
fault i think john should have
been able to properly determine this and
gone through every single one of our
patrons individually to make sure you
specifically brian did not get [ __ ]
over in the end but you got combed over
by us i'm so sorry brian perry i gotta
say though as someone who didn't
actually get the shout out that you
actually still stuck around with us
regardless of you not getting the tier
that was properly they're supposed to be
properly delivered to you not too many
people do that usually you know you get
some type of i want to refund i'm mad at
you for not doing this give me my money
back you didn't do that instead you
stayed pledged now we need more people
like brian perry here who go i pay for
something i didn't get it but i'm still
gonna keep paying for it
i'm not one of those people how many
patreon pages i've complained to oh my
god i lost count brian you're one of the
good ones out there you got a heart of
gold where money's not everything and
yet you still stayed pledged you're a
patient cat bro a lot of character you
were the first person we were shouting
out in the month of july love you brian
thank you for being you i better not see
a patreon refund request coming in now
[Music]